hi my name is Chris Gagne and I'm an
agile coach today I'm going to talk
about the trade-off matrix when working
on a software project there are four key
levers that you can manipulate scope
schedule resources and quality scope is
the total quantity of functionality and
features you plan to develop schedule is
when you make your releases available to
your end-users resources is the number
of people and teams working on your
project quality is quality including the
number of bugs documentation amount of
technical debt and the degree of
automation in your code let's take
quality off the table as a lever right
from the start and the long run quality
is free this is because if you're
compromising quality in the short term
to ship a given scope on a given date
with a fixed number of resources you
will incur a lot of technical debt
that's going to make development slower
in the long run so never compromising
quality you don't need to do overdo it
either but find the right balance
that leaves scope schedule and resources
we don't have much information at the
beginning of the project so any
predictions we try to make about the
delivery of a project will be wrong in
the beginning of a project these
estimates can easily be off by a factor
of four or more so if we try to fix
scope schedule and resources we will
almost certainly have to compromise on
work-life balance and quality and again
neither of these approaches work in the
long run so the best approach is to
negotiate with stakeholders in advance
as to what will be fixed firm and
flexible with respect to scope schedule
and resources only one of these can be
fixed firm and flexible
therefore there are six possible
approaches my favorite approach is fixed
resources firm date and flexible scope I
like having fixed resources because
according to Brookes law adding people
to a late project makes it later this is
because it takes time to ramp people up
additional people on the team producer
combinatorial explosion of communication
overhead and the work is not necessarily
divisible further having a firm date
keeps stakeholders happy and gives us a
healthy sense of urgency we can always
choose to move the date later if we wish
finally having a flexible scope demands
that we think very carefully about
incremental value delivery and user
centric iterative software development
so take the time to talk to your team
and stakeholders about the trade-off
matrix today then you will know exactly
what to do when push comes to shove and
you need to make tough decisions
together